moi je suis originaire de Paris mais ça
fait une vingtaine d'années que je suis
descendu sur Marseille et par pour mon
travail j'avais un peu plus de mal à
m'occuper de moments puisque au décès de
mon père je l'ai pris 4 ans avec moi
d'accord et donc on a vraiment essayé de
trouver la maison de retraite en tout
cas l'EHPAD idéal parce que c'est vrai
que dans la plupart des EHPAD que j'ai
visité
c'est des morts ça sent pas forcément
bon alors je suis un peu cru mais c'est
la réalité et on a opté pour cette
résidence qui est somme toute bien et
qui a aussi l'avantage d'être à 5
minutes en voiture de chez ma petite
sœur d'accord donc ceci est dans on a
opté pour cette résidence dans quel état
elle était à votre maman avant de
rentrer là-bas
alors en 2020 donc il y a deux ans trois
ans février 2020 enfin ça fait trois ans
elle était c'était une femme de 81 ans
82 ans elle avait un peu de mal à se
déplacer mais elle se déplaçait avec une
canne avec difficulté mais elle se
déplaçait au niveau santé elle n'avait
rien hormis quelques petits AVC qu'elle
avait eu et qui avait atrophilippe
partie du cerveau qui gère la mémoire
courte donc en fait elle est capable de
vous tenir une discussion avec vous puis
de mise après c'est fini en revanche
elle va vous réciter sa poésie qu'elle a
appris à 12 ans moi me reconnaît pardon
d'accord et elle surtout à deux reprises
elle a été diagnostiquée par les
gériatres ni Parkinson ni Alzheimer
d'accord c'est important pour la suite
vous allez voir l'histoire alors vous
pouvez le dire oui en fait je le dirai
dans les dans l'évolution mais ce qui
s'est passé très vite c'est que dès
qu'on l'a mis ils l'ont mis dans un
fauteuil roulant d'accord c'est un
sketch
le programme ils nous mais vous
inquiétez pas la famille on fait ça
parce que quelquefois on est à peu
pressé pour emmener tous les résidents à
la salle de restauration donc c'est pour
gagner un peu de temps dans tact pas de
souci sauf que de l'occasionnelle c'est
passé aux permanence et aujourd'hui ma
mère à part quand elle dort les dans son
lit sinon tout le reste des 24 Heures
allait sur fauteuil roulant alors
qu'elle pouvait se déplacer elle peut
encore se déplacer alors évidemment plus
difficilement aujourd'hui parce qu'elle
a perdu ses muscles mais nous quand on
vient elle est devant la barre comme
comme ici par exemple elle se lève si on
met le musique qu'elle adore elle se met
à danser évidemment on va pas faire la
gigue mais elle peut se déplacer alors
pensez avoir choisi le meilleur
établissement pourtant rapidement vous
remarquez que la santé de votre maman se
dégrade qu'est-ce qui se passe
il se passe que au-delà de l'avoir mis
tout en permanence dans le fauteuil
roulant et qu'elle ne marchait plus on a
demandé vous faites pas assez de séances
de kiné oui mais vous comprenez votre
maman elle est malade c'est sa maladie
qui l'a fait dégénérer au niveau de la
marche nous on n'était pas du tout
d'accord donc ils nous ont dit ils nous
ont fortement recommandé d'aller voir un
jariaque chose qu'on a fait et le
jarrière tu as déterminé que encore une
fois n'était ni Alzheimer ni Parkinson
mais qu'en plus elle n'avait aucune
maladie qui l'empêchait de marcher en
revanche il fallait absolument lui faire
continuer faire plusieurs fois par
semaine des séances de kinés mais
surtout avec de la stimulation active
depuis
on demande ce qui a été mis en place et
on a une fin de nos recevoir c'est on
nous répond pas j'en avais parlé au
personnel d'établissement tout ça
personne dit rien personne ne dit rien
nous on va pas un criminer le personnel
en fait il se cache derrière la fameuse
phrase nous n'avons pas assez de
personnel d'accord qui est vrai
évidemment qui est vrai vous payez
combien 3500 euros par mois c'est énorme
ils ont passé de personnel 3500
par mois on a envie d'être tranquille
c'est ce que j'ai dit dans un article et
que ça a des plus fortement au directeur
de la communication du groupe quand j'ai
dit que j'aimerais qu'on fasse le calcul
rapidement 300 3500 € par mois par 80
résidents c'est ça c'est 180000 € par
mois donc qu'est-ce que vous foutez de
cet argent ou plutôt combien réellement
ma mère vous coûte parce que quand on
dit il y a un surveillant enfin un un
soignant quand il est soignant diplômé
il y a un soignant pour 11 résidents
font des profils de fou et surtout si je
peux me permettre il y a un article qui
est sorti dans Le Parisien où monsieur a
témoigné sur les différents griefs ils
ont rappelé juste pour dire il y a une
erreur sur le prix c'est pas 3005 c'est
3003 et c'est pas 80 résidents c'est 82
non mais attendez je vous parle des
griefs de maltraitance et vous me
répondez on s'est trompé sur le montant
exact de la chambre et qu'on s'est
trompé sur le nombre précis de résident
on peut s'attendre surprenant comme ça
alors aujourd'hui votre maman elle va
comment
et moi j'appelle ça de la maltraitance
dès qu'elle est arrivée on lui a mis des
couches culottes jour et nuit
donc quand j'ai vu ça et surtout quand
on a vu qu'elle faisait des infections
rénales répétition infection rénale qui
a été vu détecté par ma petite sœur
quant à l'aller la voir parce que une
voyait rien il nous en dit oui mais vous
comprenez votre maman votre maman il
faut lui mettre des couches parce
qu'elle se déplacement ceci cela donc
moi j'ai pris la colère je suis remonté
à Paris j'étais voilà le cadre chef et
je dis écoutez je vais poser qu'une
seule question qu'est-ce qui vous incite
vous soignante à mettre une couche
culotte à un être humain
et là elle a compris a dit oui mais
c'est parce que votre maman des pertur
n'a pas de perte elle est même pas un
continent alors si c'est comme ça je
pense que vous devriez aller voir un
urologue si tu vas le passer pour
l'emmener à chaque fois c'est pour
favoriser la dépendance pour aller plus
vite donc on a été voir le rologue nous
on vous l'a absolument avoir des armes
pour leur dire regardez c'est vous qui
dites des bêtises maman elle est pas
indépendante
ou
[Musique]
donc on a pris rendez-vous avec le
relais urologue a demandé à
l'établissement de prendre un fichier et
de remplir les nombre de fois qu'ils
allaient emmener maman aux toilettes
s'appelle un planning je sais plus
comment bref peu importe et quand il
avait le planning il a ausculté maman et
il lui a fait faire aussi une
échographie de la V6 s'est rendu compte
que la vessie tu es bien vide donc elle
sait faire pipi et elle sait détecter
qu'on a envie de faire pipi et surtout
il a certifié qu'elle n'était pas un
continent
on a ramené le document à la Résidence
ils ont répondu ah oui mais non mais on
conteste parce que ils sont heureux
donc ils ont contesté donc ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui elle fait des infections
rénérables
qu'ils ont trouvé plutôt que de se lever
et d'aller l'emmener aux toilette quand
on a envie parce qu'en plus c'est pas ça
c'est que quand vous avez quelqu'un qui
vous demande d'aller aux toilettes
qu'est-ce que vous faites on est aux
toilettes si encore c'était une personne
qui s'en rendait pas compte mais c'est
pas le cas donc pour parer aujourd'hui à
l'urgence pour éviter les infections
rénaires ben la garde antibiotique c'est
ça ok aujourd'hui elle y est toujours
aujourd'hui malheureusement il est
toujours donc là c'est le moins pire
donc ça actuellement elle y est là oui
d'ailleurs
pour son bien-être elle doit appeler ses
enfants chaque soir ils doivent appeler
pour elle chez l'enfant chaque soir ce
soir c'était mon tour bref il a pas
sonné le téléphone
ils m'appellent ils attendent pas je
réponds ils jettent le téléphone à ma
mère alors des fois elle l'a pas bien
sur l'oreille bien sûr vous êtes le
casse-couille de service pour
par mois oui et vous voyez votre
mine de rien l'état de votre maman se
dégrader c'est moi franchement voilà
il est tombé
oui c'est déjà arrivé qu'elle tombe et
préviennent pas forcément en fait c'est
pour ça qu'en plus de la colère on a
inquiet
en fait ça lui a déjà rêvé d'avoir la
cheville de foulée alors qu'elle est en
fauteuil roulant ça je comprends pas une
autre fois ma petite sœur s'est rendu
compte qu'elle avait le les cheveux qui
étaient collés par le sang
parce qu'elle avait une plaie
à l'arrière du crâne
et là
elle a ils ont appelé ma petite sœur en
disant oui excusez-moi en disant qu'elle
était tombée
voilà ils l'ont pas amené aux urgences
s'ils n'ont pas fait de radio alors ils
ont appelé ma petite sœur qui a dit
écouter de la musique ça sert peut-être
rien et il me dit oui on va la
surveiller faut la surveiller ma serie
est allé dès qu'elle a quitté le travail
et elle a pris une photo d'ailleurs ma
mère était toute seule dans le salon
dans le salon il y a tout le monde sur
son fauteuil roulant en train de dormir
devant la télé en fait regardez pas la
télé c'est la télé qui l'a regardé
et le problème c'est ça c'est qui il
font tout alors encore une fois je vais
l'incrimine pas le personnel mais ils
font tout mais pour se débarrasser des
tâches difficiles et surtout s'ils n'ont
pas véritablement la quantité de
personnes qu'il faut ben voilà alors le
le la dernière chose c'est qu'on a été
excusez-moi dernière chose c'est qu'on a
été obligé de fermer dans notre propre
kiné parce qu'il se refusait de nous
dire ce qu'ils avaient mis exactement en
place
il se refusait de nous dire exactement
ce qu'ils avaient mis en place et là on
vient d'apprendre que ils ont demandé
l'autorisation à notre kiné de pouvoir
faire installer dans la chambre de ma
mère un appareil qui s'appelle stand-up
en fait c'est simple vous parlez de
viande tout à l'heure c'est une machine
qui va soulever ma mère pour qu'il
puisse se prendre la douche parce qu'ils
ont mal au dos en fait une viande ma
mère et en plus vous avez payé le kiné
donc et je vois pas le Quino
donne 3500 euros par mois on a envie on
a envie d'être tranquille le fauteuil
roulant vous avez vous voyez là j'ai été
obligé de négocier avec le pharmacien
parce que c'est celui que j'avais loué
quand je faisais des grandes balades au
bord de mer avec ma mère ils l'ont gardé
presque voler pourtant ils ont de
dotation de de la RS alors on a la
chance d'avoir le ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées en France Merci
monsieur le ministre déjà un an après le
scandale Europa est-ce qu'on en est où
est-ce que ça avance
des ehpads de notre pays il y en a 1400
qui ont déjà été
je peux me permettre monsieur je sais
qu'il y a des contrôles problème qu'il y
a c'est qu'ils savent qu'il y a des
contrôles et que c'est comme c'est comme
dans le film La l'aile ou la cuisse
voilà quand ils savent qui est un mec
qui va venir tout est nickel et donc
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a les moyens de faire
des contrôles sauvages est-ce que c'est
possible ou pas on le fait dans la
restauration
on décide de courtoisie en fait on a
construit des contrôles de façon extrême
sérieuse il y a des contrôles qui sont
inopinés il y a des contrôles qui sont
programmés vous savez ces situations là
c'est pas parce que vous allez arriver
comme ça à l'improvise dans
l'établissement que vous allez forcément
avoir et que vous allez voir des
situations de maltraitance de négligence
qui dure depuis des années et des années
comme vous verrez pas non plus des
situations de maltraitance parce que
vous serez là maltraitance physique des
violences sexuelles des violences
psychologiques etc qui durent et donc
faire des contrôles approfondis donc qui
soit inopinés ou pas en général ça ne
change rien alors aujourd'hui
ces établissements privés on l'a vu sont
très très cher et moi je pense que c'est
pareil pour vous monsieur le ministre on
peut pas voir le le fils de cette dame
pleurer j'en ai eu plein ici sur ce
plateau il paye il se saigne pour payer
et pour voilà qui qui vendent leurs
apparts qui qui qui qui qui qui se
saigne pour payer des établissements où
ils se disent au moins je vais être
tranquille et maman va être bien traités
et là il voit la santé de leur maman se
dégrader de jour en jour aujourd'hui on
le sait et on sait comme toujours c'est
toujours le même problème c'est surtout
pour faire du profit et aujourd'hui il y
a un manque de personnel donc voilà pour
faire plus de profits et ben on réduit
le personnel on fait manger des choses
qui coûtent moins cher et voilà et on
fait payer très cher à ces personnes
aujourd'hui
au niveau de la législation c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire est-ce
qu'il est possible de dire voilà il y a
un minimum d'effectifs pour ton client
c'est à dire que pour 10 personnes on
dit voilà il faut trois personnes je
vous dis n'importe quoi est-ce que c'est
possible ou pas non mais c'est un sujet
qu'il faut qu'on aborde effectivement il
y a un lien entre le nombre de personnes
qui s'occupent d'une personne âgée et la
qualité de cet accompagnement c'est
clair la Défenseur des droits a dit
qu'il faudrait 8 soignants pour 10
résidences aujourd'hui on est environ à
6 c'est une moyenne il y a des
établissements auxquels c'est beaucoup
moins d'autres dans lesquels dans
lesquels c'est plus c'est une moyenne ça
dépend des jours aussi mais il faut il
faut qu'on continue à augmenter le
nombre de personnes on va recruter la 50
000 soignants dans les EHPAD dans les 5
années qui viennent peut-être qu'on
aille plus loin plus vite la difficulté
qu'on a aujourd'hui aussi c'est de
recruter parce que ça intéresse pas
forcément les jeunes d'aller travailler
dans ces établissements il faut qu'on
rende les métiers plus attractifs qu'on
paye mieux ces personnel au passage
cette situation elle reflète pas non
plus la majorité des établissements de
dans notre pays il y a beaucoup de il y
a beaucoup de cas aujourd'hui mais c'est
pas la très grande majorité des
établissements il y a des endroits où ça
se passe bien moi j'en visite toutes les
semaines
comme le guide Michelin je vous dis
n'importe quoi je voudrais pas y avoir
un guide aussi des EHPAD avec voilà des
notes et
nourriture voilà bah là c'est vrai bah
ça coûte plus cher parce que c'est un 3
étoiles je vous dis n'importe quoi et là
on est des critères qui soit qui soit
plus clair on vient juste d'en mettre là
des des critères ça aurait dû être fait
bien avant pour qu'on puisse pour qu'on
puisse combat et puis je voudrais
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure moi mon problème c'est enfin ça
me choque pas qu'on puisse gagner de
l'argent avec ses activités là en
revanche qui me choque c'est que les
actionnaires qui de ces entreprises là
aujourd'hui ne mettent pas en fait la
qualité de service la protection des
personnes qui sont dans ces
établissements le bien-être des salariés
avant les les gains financiers un peu
moins de profit mais plus de sécurité
pour les les passions les clients et les
résidents de de ces de ces de de de
voilà de ces maisons parce que voilà
parce que ça se contrôle
des salariés je parlerai plutôt du
bien-être des résidents même s'il faut
pas oublier les salariés parce que en
fait
quand vous dites qu'il y a en moyenne et
j'en ai fait j'en ai pas tous évidemment
mais 6 pour dire résidents moi cache je
vous le dis c'est pas possible mais
alors je m'excuse de m'adresser à vous
parce que je sais que ça fait pas
longtemps
oui c'est gentil mais je m'adresse
surtout au gouvernement l'année dernière
il y a le livre qui est sorti que dans
tout le monde parle aujourd'hui ça fait
un scandale et ça émue tout le monde
mais rien n'a bougé ma mère ça fait
trois ans qu'elle est là c'est toujours
pareil
rien ne bouge donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut
attendre parce que vraiment une dernière
question semi ça va bouger à horizon de
te combien de combien de temps voilà
mais ça bouge déjà et on va on va
accélérer les choses enfin moi je salue
le courage de Monsieur parce que c'est
ça qu'il faut faire aussi c'est libérer
la parole il faut que les gens ils osent
dire les difficultés aussi dans ces
situations là c'est que les gens n'osent
pas dire parce qu'après ils ont peur que
ça amplifie ou que ça aggrave la
situation aujourd'hui il faut libérer la
parole faut plus que ce soit un tabou et
d'ailleurs j'observe qu'il y a de plus
en plus de de plaintes aussi parce que
les gens ils osent parler il faut que
nous de notre côté du côté des pouvoirs
publics on sache aussi d'aller prendre
en considération les accompagner et
avoir des réponses qui soient adaptées
mais ça va changer ça change déjà et ça
va continuer à changer et vite on peut
plus tolérer ce type de situation vous
parler des salariés c'est extrêmement
important si demain les gens ils veulent
plus venir travailler dans les EHPAD on
va pas améliorer la situation
mais c'est important